this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money i am ramsey personality and
best-selling author rachel cruz
and next me today co-hosting is ramsey
personality and best-selling author
christy wright
this is fun i can't believe they let us
do this and now we get to meet together
if we're real-life friends the fact that
we get to
have a microphone for america it's a
little scary i wonder how nervous james
gets on fridays when we're together it's
fun how are you feeling james you okay
it's gonna be great
but we are gonna answer your questions
again about life and money um and you i
mean in life balance too can we just
throw those things let's throw that in
because i always think that's a very
interesting
subject matter in our world today yeah
and your book
that has launched right into the world i
know it's all on this just just over a
week and there's such a correlation
between
the problem we have with time the
struggles we have with time and the
struggles we have with money because it
takes time to work a second job it takes
time to reach your goals it takes time
to dig yourself out of debt these things
don't happen by accident and we give
people the money plan
but of course there's a time implication
of that and so i just think there is
such a connection between what i'm doing
with my new book take back your time the
guilt-free guide to life balance to show
you
how you can reach your goals and even be
gazelle intense and baby step two by the
way you have permission to focus yeah on
the right things at the right time and
uh and it's such a connection with what
we are known for as a company of being
the people that help people get out of
debt and uh take control their money so
it's super exciting even though it feels
like a different topic it's really not
it really is completely connected to
what we do oh 100 yes and it's just it's
it is life and that's what i that's
those are the subjects i obviously love
to dive into but it is i'm like whether
you're
a mom with four kids trying to juggle it
all whether you're single whether you're
retired all of it we all have a set
amount of time and how we use it it just
feels like it's so so keen so important
in the fact that you hit on that i love
so much so uh give us a call at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
so we'll go to sarah and sacramento hey
sarah welcome to the show
hi um thank you guys for having me i
just had a quick question hopefully um i
can get an answer from you guys but
basically i started um reading the money
makeover and right now my partner and i
are in the process of
saving money towards fertility
treatments and i but i want to start the
money makeover because i have about
forty four thousand dollars um just in
uh
either car loan um personal loan
um
and on uh sorry an ac unit as well um so
um i was just curious should i start the
money makeover
maybe continue saving for the fertility
treatments
yeah i guess i'm just new no it's a
great question
how much money do you matter or how was
your household um i'm just under uh just
me i'm just under a hundred thousand
okay and how much i don't know how much
the fertility treatments are how much
are those
um
we're estimating right now so we're
doing a whole bunch of research it's
maybe between like five and eight
thousand okay
and um i do i might i was just going to
mention on my car i have about 15 000
left and i know i can sell it right now
for probably about 35 wow i was
considering maybe selling it
taking the money and just paying down as
much debt as possible
yes and then
that's going to be a yes there yes yes
from us well that's amazing i mean
because yeah i think part of and as you
read the book but but part of this idea
of and i love how motivated you are
right you're like i really want to start
this
is
how you can decrease lifestyle how you
can up your income and part of that
equation is selling stuff and so you're
looking around say okay what are things
that i can just sell and make money as
quickly as possible to put towards this
and so thing assets even like a car and
especially since you still have debt on
it it's like yeah
you can wipe that out and ken coleman
and i were on the show yesterday talking
about this because it got brought up
multiple times but how you can find an
an amazing a really great five thousand
dollar car yeah they're everywhere
they're everywhere just for the season
that's right just for this amount of
time and that will knock out gosh i mean
you only have nine thousand dollars left
of debt and with your income
you're going to be able to get out of
debt so very quickly within probably six
months or less if you are really gazelle
intense um and then you're going to be
able to save up for that so i think you
can do a lot of this
and even just the calendar year
to start that process because i know
starting a family is is very important
and i'm so pro that i think that it's
it's amazing and especially since you're
having to go down this route you know
timeline and stuff may be a little
different but
um but yeah i would for sure yeah sell
the car and start working your way out
well it's a different conversation too
sarah because you're only putting off
these fertility treatments for a few
months we're not talking about putting
it off for five years because you've got
this huge mountain of debt you don't you
have forty thousand dollars you've got a
way to get out of it pretty quickly save
up for the fertility treatments and then
you're going down that path which i
would imagine from the friends that i've
had that have gone down that path it's
very emotional and so you want to go
down that path with less stress as
possible and so if you're able to knock
out this debt you can pursue that
without that debt weighing you down with
just a clear head so i i love that idea
of you getting out of debt quickly and
um and then pursuing that goal which is
awesome yeah yeah and this is you know
the the family unit if you will of this
process is an important one because
there's multiple conversations to be had
so those of you
that have kids and you're starting this
process bringing them in yeah and making
it a family affair if you will of this
process of cutting lifestyle getting out
of debt bringing them along those of you
out there that are expecting if you are
pregnant about to have a baby we always
say press pause on the debt snowball
and save up as much money as possible
and then once baby is here and mom is
good then you can write a big check and
knock out a bunch of your debts um and
then in this case we do get a lot of
questions about fertility treatments
because they can be extreme extremely
expensive
um and it is it is a very emotional
process and
it it does what you said chris i think
was so spot on though it gives you peace
when you don't have the debt and when
you don't go into debt for it right
which is always a hard
piece of advice for me to give for
people when they ask can i go into debt
for this because i want a family and i'm
like oh
because i've heard the other stories of
it that's right sadly not working and
you're making those payments you're
making payments and all that and then
you want to adopt and then there's you
know it just is all this but if you can
just
steady and have your goals
bring in more income if you can and
focus on what you want you can do it you
can do all of it right yeah um but it's
just a matter of kind of taking a deep
breath and not just jumping in on
complete emotions well and people often
call in and ask us about well i know the
baby steps are in this order because but
here's my situation but i think i'm an
exception to the rule but and there are
a handful of things like pressing pause
when you're expecting that type of thing
but for the most part these baby steps
are proven and laid out in this order
for a reason and it's because we want
you to go into having a family go into
buying a house go into these big
exciting and stressful and emotional
life changes debt-free when you can and
so it's it's it we lay it out that way
for a reason and um and i think sarah
you're going to experience it very
differently when you don't have that
debt weighing you down and the stress of
the payments and uh and we're so excited
for you that's all and you have a great
income too sarah i mean you're gonna be
able to knock a lot of this out which is
so great
so awesome well again you can give us a
call at triple eight 825-5225
taking your questions here on the ramsey
show
[Music]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
blinds.com 100 satisfaction guarantee
means even if you mismeasure or pick the
wrong color they'll remake your blinds
for free you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promo codes
they run every month you'll save even
more use promo code ramsay to get the
best deal rules and restrictions apply
today's question comes from cali in ohio
i'm a teacher and i have a two-year-old
child my husband and i are working on
baby step two and should have our debt
paid off in 23 months after we get out
of debt we plan on having a second child
i would love more than anything to quit
my job and stay at home but my husband
is not on board i make 2 000 a month and
getting out of debt will save us 1400 a
month our budget would be tight but
doable
how do i convince him to let me stay at
home
this is a good one
so so my first question if if cali were
here and i could ask her a follow-up i
would be curious what their current
child care situation is because often
people dismiss the it can can be
exorbitant cost of child care 100 yeah
and when women choose to stay home it's
not right for everybody but for those
who want to do that and it's right for
them
often them staying home is saving them
more in child care than they're making
in their full-time job so it just makes
sense yes for them to do that from a
financial standpoint if that's all
you're looking at so i'm just curious
i'm assuming a parent or someone is
watching this child and would watch the
second child so they're basically
getting free child care which is why
that extra income makes a difference but
um but looking at the cost of child care
sometimes it's not just that but man
i've noticed with matt rachel he is so
factual and so logical that i can i can
talk at the feelings level and he's just
like hmm okay but when i talk number
words when i talk numbers yeah he seems
to lights up yeah he connects more so i
would say that looking at the numbers
and talking about that now if that's not
an equation um one of the things that
i've always um done in my in any
conversation for that matter
is you really speak to the why why you
want to why it's important to you
and that can can again bring a deeper
level to the communication to the
discussion versus staying at the surface
where people kind of miss each other
absolutely and i think that that
connection point is key and so for you
guys
yeah i think you're right mapping out
the numbers which i think is one way to
get a husband on board of just getting
out of debt that's a question a lot is
how do i get my how do i get my husband
on board or my spouse on board when you
just look at the time frame you realize
okay it's not that long
in in the grand scheme of life right
maybe two three years 18 months to
really buckle down and get rid of this
debt
and then when it when you are debt-free
it does free up the options and it does
free up in what she was saying of how
much they'd save a month versus what she
makes a month i'm like man you could
still quit your job yeah and be able to
save that amount of money when you don't
have the payments and so it is it's a
it's a it's a
it's such a family values
conversation as well and there's not a
right or wrong in it right like what
you're saying um of the stay-at-home
portion and so you guys getting on the
same page and again talking about your
why i think is is so important well the
other thing that i think is is good and
matt might roll his eyes if he heard me
say this but i think just continuing to
revisit the conversation don't look at
us i'm gonna have this conversation once
we don't agree so then we're just at a
standstill matt and i when we've had
things that we disagree on everything
from big things to small things small
stupid stuff like where we put the fence
in our yard like right we just circle
back to it circle back to it discuss it
you know look at it through other angles
well what are your concerns what are my
concerns is there a common ground um
when you just continue to work through
it oftentimes you will find how you can
come together but if you see it as well
we talked one time six years ago and he
said no right well we got to be a little
more persistent than that we've got to
keep working on it care enough about
your relationship and being on the same
page and this decision to continue to
work through it and try absolutely and
we're taking your calls again about life
and money at triple eight eight two five
five two two five so let's go to holly
and new hampshire hey holly welcome
to the show i think we lost holly that's
okay should we lose her i think so maybe
she'll come back that's okay she had a
great question i know
family questions are the hardest though
i think i think holly had a family
question this this question from cali as
a family question those can be hard
because there are financial principles
that we teach
and those are proven we have three
decades of proof we have millions of
families that have been changed by them
and when you add the family dynamic when
you add the family values of like hey i
don't feel represented in the budget or
my husband and i disagree on how we
should spend this ten thousand dollars
for example he wants a motorcycle i want
to put it towards the house you know
those are hard because you you have to
have these conversations to get on the
same page and that's less formulaic is
that a weirdness yes no it is it's less
a formula and more of the emotional
communication connection
which is which is such a huge issue here
let's try again
paulie are you there hi
i'm here how are you ladies are you
doing great how are you
pretty good bless thank you absolutely
how can we help
well i am currently reworking our budget
um our income just about quadrupled with
my husband finishing school oh wow
debt-free by the way we've got no
student loans
thank you
um so i'm a little overwhelmed with the
change but i guess my main question
is
as a stay-at-home mom
should i be getting some sort of
allowance how do i account for
my spending money and out and in our
budget based on his income oh
i have some thoughts on this holly i
have some thoughts based on how you ask
the question jump in
how do i get an allowance
holly
this is not your husband's money
this is y'all's money
you're married you're correct
yes okay
are the children just your children are
they his children too no no no we've got
um one son together and we've got one on
the way okay congratulations and
when you walk down the aisle you became
one you decided to share your life your
time your money your children all the
things so i want to break this idea that
you are getting money from your spouse
that you are one with that you're
getting an allowance or spending money
even how you asked it i think the
premise of that
is off because it's not his money it's
y'all's money and by the way we were
just talking about this um on the
blinds.com question but there is an
unbelievable cost of child care if you
were to replace yourself
through child care and run the numbers
of two kids in child care that alone at
the baseline is the value the financial
dollar amount that you're bringing to
your family on paper on the budget so i
want to start by just questioning the
premise of how do i get money from him
this this to me is not even a question
this is y'all's money and y'all like we
were just saying make decisions together
yeah and and holly i'm i'm assuming i
don't want well i don't want to assume
so i'll ask you are you feeling oh you
guys feeling overwhelmed when you said
he quadrupled his income so you guys are
making
more money than you probably ever even
imagined you know so is that feeling
very overwhelming to you
um a little bit because i just want to
make sure that we're doing the right
things with the money and we've been
following the baby steps and um always
all the debt we have actually i paid off
one of our car notes yesterday
congratulations and so all we've got is
just my car now left to pay off and i
want to be clear that um
he doesn't
uh feel that this is his money it is
totally understood that this is our
money
my main question i guess is just
more of a budget perspective of what
does it look like yes
yes so what i would say for you guys
since you are coming in to
more money than than you've had right um
is to increase your lifestyle a little
bit at a time so the budget that you
guys have been having
just up some categories 10 20
maybe even just 10 depending on the
dollar amount and say okay i'm gonna
we're going to up that miscellaneous
we're going to up out to eat we're
you need to get out of debt first first
and foremost all that all that cash but
yeah this is this is once kind of that
is all paid off which i'm assuming is
gonna happen very quickly
and and to be able to say okay yes i you
have a line item in the budget he has a
line in the budget and it may feel weird
at first like okay we're going to up
these dollar amounts
um but you're going to be able to
because you're going to have the margin
once you're debt-free and you have that
emergency fund in place to be able to do
that
and so do it slowly over time because
you're not going to it's going to feel
out of control if you're like okay let's
just live on this and it's going to feel
great and we're just going to go at it
that's a little bit where the insecurity
can happen for a while
yes absolutely so just wade into it
and get used to it and then also holly
making sure that you're up in your
giving as well
and so the lifestyle can be upped a
little bit and the giving and both of
these things is going to really
start to allow these new habits to form
on how to handle and steward really what
god has given you guys in an amazing way
but again holly getting out of debt that
emergency fund that needs to be
first priority before anything else but
then to be able to say hey yeah we each
get some some fun money and there
shouldn't be guilt for that yeah when
you have a conversation and you're both
represented in the budget then you're
putting on paper that you both have
value in the budget and you do and
that's going to be a fun conversation
now that you have so much more money
absolutely this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well in the lobby of ramsey solutions on
the free stage we have brandon and
hannah with us welcome you guys hi thank
you hi so you're staying on that special
stage for one reason we sure are what
are you here for we're here to do our
debt-free scream yes
amazing amazing okay where are you guys
from
we're from northwest iowa okay iowa and
how much debt did you guys pay off
we paid off fifty two thousand dollars
fifty twenty thousand amazing and what
kind of income were you making during
that time we started at 95 000 and we
ended currently at 105 000. that's nice
and how long did it take you
18 months 18 months
oh man you guys so what was the 52 000
it included a lot of things your normal
student loans vehicle loans we had
credit cards a line of credit um
different things like that pretty normal
normal pretty normal variety yes not a
good thing to be normal
that's right what happened uh what
happened a year and a half ago what set
you on this path so kind of a weird
story uh i love weird stories go on
hannah we're here for it people have
weird
so it's around the same time that one of
my family members kind of sent me a
message saying hey that there's this
program at my church you know you and
brandon should come to it you know it's
called financial peace university
you know here's the times and things
like that well the same day i came home
and brandon came up to me
and he starts talking about this friend
um
carl who actually turned into our
financial peace university coordinator
who is here today celebrating with us
cool so
shout out to carl we're very
appreciative of himself yes
okay so then brenda how do you know carl
what was the connection there he's
actually a childhood friend so as i grew
up he was a good friend with my dad and
i was familiar with his social media
posts and stuff about it so you just
heard from him via social media you saw
something yep and the same day the stars
are weird god was like all right
we came home and he was like hey i have
this you know carl friend he was telling
me about fpu and i was like well weird
because my cousin was just telling me
about it and we just jumped right in
yeah it was amazing so you took the
class yep you started down the journey
yep and
what what do you few what was the
feeling like when you started it because
obviously you both were on board which
is very impressive you know very very
helpful
so what what were you feeling in your
life and in your money in your marriage
18 months ago and then what's the
difference standing on that stage today
well so 18 months ago we were just
engaged um so it was kind of something
that we both you know heard about talked
about that week and we were like well
why not just start it now so that we can
you know roll into the marriage uh on
you know the right foot and have
everything set up for success um and i
think you know our inspiration came from
you know watching you know my family
kind of have some financial issues and
things like that and you know maybe not
being on the right page most of the time
and i think brandon had some similar
experiences
so we wanted to set ourselves up for
success and being able to see that you
know we wanted to be on the right foot
like i said um so just having you know
everything ready not going into our
first year of marriage which we're
celebrating our anniversary this weekend
we didn't want to be in debt so yeah we
wanted to be on the same page and be
successful that's awesome did starting
the plan since you guys started when you
were engaged did it bring about some
really interesting conversation like
what you value and how you spend money
and how you view money i mean this is
what rachel's book is about know
yourself know your money is that
something because i think that's
probably really cool to get to have
those talks even before you walk down
the aisle yeah yeah we were definitely
on the same page um you know we
obviously had rocky moments just like
any relationship with finances and
things like that but i don't think
either of us wanted it to be a hindrance
like it is for most relationships you
know we were both honest with each other
whether or not we wanted to be you know
there were some hard spots like i said
but um i don't know i think just being
on the same page you know it opened up a
lot of conversations that we could get
out of the way and just have clear air
and just go about
go about everything else so brandon for
you what was the hardest part of that 18
months
um
at first it was us being on the same
page and then going to the class and
kind of learning a little bit about it
but once we both learned about it we
both held each other accountable which
was the fantastic thing i think that
hannah my wife did a fantastic job
throughout it and i think that i kind of
built off what she was doing and then i
learned a lot from her as well
that's awesome but you guys planned to i
mean you had a wedding during this time
so i mean talk me through that because
there's people out there that think i
can't you know i can't have a wedding
without going into debt or there's no
way i can get out of debt and get
married i mean you guys you did both so
yeah we'll be honest with you it was not
easy
we cash flowed our wedding so we were
safe we were putting 600 800 bucks a
month towards the wedding for six six
eight months and then we ended up paying
12 to 15 thousand dollars somewhere in
there for the wedding we didn't have a
huge wedding we didn't have a small
wedding but it was a nice wedding
perfect yeah it was everything i needed
to be and we had help from my family as
well and we're so thankful for our
family we've had so many cheerleaders
and friends and everything like that be
there to back us up um we do have the
occasional friend that's kind of like
that's a little weird you know why are
you doing this um but it is so worth it
and i just i tell them what i can and we
go about it and we just do our thing and
yeah it's so worth it that's awesome
what what do you say that what do you
say the key is i know you said
accountability brandon what is the and
from in terms of a tactical thing that
you guys did what was what made you be
able to last and and finish the plan and
actually become debt free do you think
in my opinion i think it was the big
picture i think you know we think we
think in the future for us and we don't
we don't we want our our kids to see us
be successful yeah when we get older we
want to be debt free we want to be able
to buy nice things without having to
take out loans for it i'm not a fan of
borrowing money i never have been so i
think that the idea for us being
financially stable being on the same
page and i think it just correlates
directly into our marriage yeah so that
that is a big thing for me absolutely
well it's powerful you guys i mean you i
know you said it was difficult and
there's hard spots and all of that but
you i mean i'm impressed you guys i mean
they're like listen we came together one
day had a conversation like we're
signing up we're doing this okay we're
gonna plan a wedding and get married in
the middle of it and we're gonna knock
it out in 18 months i mean you guys just
did it you were focused we were full on
and we sold our truck i mean we sold our
house
we did a lot of selling of personal
property that we just didn't need
i've been kind of saying a couple
mantras to myself you know if it's not
in my life then i don't need it you know
kind of thing and it's just kind of
things to help me you know get through
it you know i don't need that extra set
of shoes that look really nice over
there yeah you know i would rather save
that money for something that we need
and things like that so yeah we sold the
truck um the house we picked up a lot of
extra shifts i know brandon um he's
picked up a lot of extra gigs
you know doing security and things like
that and then extra hours you know i'm
trying to shoot between 40 and 60 hours
a week just working and saving all the
money what do you guys do i'm a deputy
sheriff oh cool and i'm a veterinary
technician awesome okay very cool well
done you guys well and how old are you
guys i'm 26 years old and i'm 25 26 and
25 and debt free and debt free isn't
that amazing you guys i mean fantastic
you got it it is it's unbelievable there
are so many people listening right now
that just think if i only did that
that's right in my early you know
mid-20s right how different things would
be and and you guys are right like you
said you're setting up this legacy for
your family to come and setting up this
marriage where
it's just it's not a stress point you
know you're on the same page and it's
it's absolutely beautiful i mean you
guys are textbook exactly what it feels
like selling stuff picking up extra work
and you and you did it in 18 months and
now your entire lives are ahead of you
which is absolutely incredible well
congratulations you guys we've got a
copy of the legacy journey for you and
the total money makeover for you to pass
it on for someone else so you can give
that away
all right brandon and hannah from iowa
paid off 52 000
while making 95 to 100
105 000
count it down let's hear a big debt-free
scream
three two one
amazing
i love that they came home on the same
day and go hey have you heard of
financial peace university hey i've got
this idea like they never struggled with
the how do i get my spouse on board
conversation we spent some time talking
about that today and they never
struggled with that they came home on
the same day with the same idea and
you're like
wait you mean this do you want to do
this too oh it's beautiful yeah no
coincidences that we believe that was a
god timing for sure that's exactly right
and just to you know and and i love what
she said even to you know if it's not my
life i don't need it and and this
process it does something to you when
you start
purging
selling stuff not buying things that you
just want in the moment
stuff and what money plays in your life
it starts to change you look at your
life and yourself differently yeah in a
more healthy way i think absolutely
absolutely oh well congratulations again
to brandon and hannah absolutely
incredible this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
welcome to the ramsay show
christy wright
and myself are here taking your
questions and christy you have you've
had some fun stuff happening i feel like
launching in the past
this has been the fall of christie right
yeah
it's so great i love it i love it
there's a lot going on we've got the
take back your time back business
boutique is coming up but the thing that
i think people have been asking about
the most because it's so calendar
sensitive literally
is the goal planner and y'all y'all know
i talk about this all the time but
trying to balance everything that you've
got going on and
reach your goals can be really really
hard and so we love to give you tools
where you can put your plans on paper
research shows by the way that when you
write something down you're almost 50
more likely to do it
so i've got a tool for you my new 2022
goal planner is here this is our fourth
year doing it every year we order more
every year they sell out and no we don't
order more after they sell out because
y'all
it's a calendar it obviously is time
sensitive so when they sell out they're
gone
and you want to get one you know it's
going to help you manage your schedule
grow as a person i've got content in
there every single month that helps you
focus on a different area of your life
we've got the monthly calendar the
weekly calendar journal questions for
reflection and even tools and templates
to help you do what i'm teaching you to
do so if you want to get your copy and i
suggest you do whether it's a christmas
present or for yourself go to
ramseysolutions.com they will sell out
and uh you can get yours before they do
yeah that's a great i love hearing the
feedback on these yes people love them
well it's two things and one it's just
beautiful when you see it you're like
our design team it's so painful
so good and then number two i mean the
the still writing it down the tactic it
is so people i mean
their planners are their life and so
this is it and then it adds obviously so
much stuff with the content and
everything so
absolutely amazing all right michelle
from north carolina
welcome to the show yes thank you
absolutely how can we help
um yes i was wondering how what is a
good amount besides the 15
to put away what is it
i just bought a half a year ago about a
year and a half ago okay and i'm fine i
have a car payment and a house payment
and i have a 16 year old and i'm a
single mom okay so
i'm just wondering i know that uh oh
it's gonna happen
so i don't want to
have it happen without being prepared
absolutely michelle are you new to
listening to us
um actually mr ramsey had started me
with my own business i wanted to thank
him as well cool i cleaned house for a
living and i worked for someone else and
he said well you need to do more so i
went off on my own wonderful good for
you
so michelle do you have any savings just
cash in a savings account or anything do
you have anything there
yeah
how much do you have
15 000. you have 15 000 saved yeah okay
and how much is how much is the car loan
a month a month how much is it total how
much do you do you owe on the car
oh i see um probably about 14. about 14
000 okay well that is just perfect
michelle yes
so
oh
how much how much are you making
cleaning houses michelle per year would
you say
for the year about 25. about 25 000 okay
well you are
you're in it you're in a great position
in a sense when we talk about the baby
steps because you literally could knock
out two baby steps when we get off the
phone um you can take
that 14 000 you have saved um
pay off the car get that out of here
and then start saving not just 15 so the
15 we save is for retirement which is
baby step four so i want to back you up
a little bit after that car is paid off
baby step three
is to save three to six months worth of
expenses
and so
i would say depending on i mean you're
you're a single mom
um
and i'm sure there's somewhat consistent
income but if i were you i would lean
toward that six month mark
um so that would be probably saving up i
don't know for you whatever that is for
you um i'm guessing probably around ten
thousand or so could be about six months
worth well
especially because your income is
dependent upon you
pres running your business where if you
had a health situation you couldn't work
you don't get paid whereas other people
could take time off and still get paid
so that's
that's a huge part of it yes so i would
i would say um
when we get off the call michelle i
would i would i would pay off the car
and then next paycheck i would start
stocking away money slowly but surely
and save up for for that six months um
right and then from there
you can start saving for retirement
which is the 15
of what i'm already doing
i'm already doing that okay so i would
press
yes that's great so if and and if you
want to look at the math i would even
press pause
on that retirement while you save up
that six months worth of expenses
because the key here is
as much as and it's only for a short
period of time you're not gonna it's not
gonna take a long time but for a short
period of time because as much cash as
you can do to have some savings to build
that savings fund back up as quickly as
possible it's gonna set you up then you
press play on retirement and you're
gonna actually have more money that
you're going to be able to throw at
retirements than you will even now
michelle how many hours a week roughly
are you working
um
about 30. is it just you
yeah okay
i want you to stay on the line i'm going
to have kelly send you a copy of my book
business boutique and give you a ticket
to the live stream event i want to get
your income up i want you to be making
more than 25 000 a year and then you're
gonna get to baby step four where you're
investing a lot faster you you run your
own business you can and should be
making more and there's a good chance
you're under charging or there's some
some tweaks that you can make and i want
to help you do that so stay on the line
we'll get you set up with the business
boutique book the business boutique
conference which is coming up october
14th through the 16th you can live
stream it from your home and that will
give you some extra tools in your tool
belt to get your income up to help you
do exactly what rachel's saying a little
bit faster absolutely
all right next up we have caleb in utah
hey caleb welcome to the show
hey thanks for taking my call absolutely
how can we help
well my wife and i we are on baby step 2
and we're going through financial peace
university
and we've realized that we want to make
a little bit more income
and so
i've been doing a wood business out of
my garage
build furniture
and i have about 10 customers on deck
and
i go up to my wood supplier
and realize that everything's about 50
percent more expensive
and so the wood is more than the actual
table for
how much it actually costs to build so
anyway
um i'm just trying to figure out the
best way to tell tell my customers
that i need more money yeah or what what
the right way is to do that because
really we're just trying
i have a full-time job as well as my
side hustle
just trying to figure out the best way
to go about it and make money that way
yeah so caleb um
your situation is incredibly common and
everyone doing anything
with building materials whether it's
homes or projects like what you're
talking about is experiencing this exact
thing so the first thing i want to tell
you is yes you can pass on that cost
increase to your customers yes you
should pass it on and the great thing is
you don't have to use i statements like
i need
because you actually don't need more
money at all what you're going to say is
you're going to put it off on the
vendor on the supplier because that's
where it's originating it's not
originating from caleb you're not
increasing your price which even if you
would and could you have a right to by
the way even if it was just increasing
um your prices but you just say it like
that you say the cost of materials has
gone up therefore the quote on this this
project is xyz and don't apologize for
it don't explain it don't justify it
don't don't talk yourself out of it
because sometimes we get nervous and
awkward and so we just talk talk talk
talk and we actually make something
bigger than it is you literally just say
the statement hey just want to let you
know um you know if it's someone you
already gave them a quote let's say you
give that that's how i was going to ask
what would you do
if you've already given him a quote
then um you just need to come back to
him say hey the cost of materials has
gone up i don't know what the delay time
is between when you give a quote and
when you actually fulfill it but you
absolutely should still pass this on
when you go to starbucks and the cost of
coffee beans has gone up we all pay it
same thing i have a friend building a
house right now
and she locked in the contract on this
house and then they came back around
said hey this disclaimer at the bottom
this clause cost of materials has gone
up this is a very normal business
practice because otherwise it's going to
put you out of business i know it's a
side hustle but you still have to have
margin for your time your labor and and
the work that you're doing so yeah you
just pass it on and uh the more you
practice saying the easier to get yep
absolutely and everyone knows that
materials it's all over the news
everyone knows it right so great well
christy always fun co-hosting with you i
love it i want to thank our producer
james charles and associate producer
kelly daniel
and you america for listening this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you are the hero in your story